He see you when you're sleeping
Yes very like dead face
(upbeat Christmas music)
Today we're gonna read
problematic Christmas lyrics
because someone needs to speak up.
Let's go into the lyrics shall we?
First song up is Santa
Claus Is Coming To Town.
Which is the beginning
of also horror movies.
Is he God?
It's either creepy stalker or I guess God.
Should we play this backwards
and see if it's like Satan is coming.
If you turn the words around,
Santa is Satan.
- [Male] I saw Mommy Kissing Santa Claus
That covers a lot of ground.
Ew.
As a child, you're used to
seeing your mom and your dad
and then suddenly this dude-
Comes out of nowhere, snatches your mom
Tickle, tickle mommy.
I don't think that would have been funny.
Oh it wouldn't have been a laugh at all.
This kid seems like he's trying
to break up a happy home.
Let's actually play it out of how
this story should have happened.
Police? Yes.
I'd like to report an adulterer.
[Girl In Green Jacket] Grandma
Got Runover By A Reindeer
Where are these Christmas
songs coming from?
You have not heard this?
No!
Claus is spelled
Santa's into some BDSM.
Grandma laid down with Santa too
and it seems like Mommy
wasn't the only person
kissing Santa Claus.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm piecing it together.
1 a.m., Grandma goes outside
for a whisky and a smoke,
sees Santa slithering down the chimney,
and invites him to do the same to her.
We should consider that maybe
this was a consensual act
between Santa Clause,
the reindeer and Grandma
and it just got a little out of hand.
Let's just have a moment
of silence for Grandma
Yeah, okay.
[Girl In Snowflake Top] Santa Baby
This is my favorite
This is a letter to her sugar daddy.
I'll do this if you do this.
Before morning.
She wants
a duplex and some checks.
So, you, she just wants straight
money also what she wants.
Yo, I need to take some
notes from Eartha man.
♪ Santa baby give money
for my rent this month. ♪
Maybe Santa is just like the
Hugh Hefner of like the world
and he's just like, kissing moms,
taking down grandmas, and
Eartha Kitt is the side chick
and they're just like a crazy
love triangle going on
Yeah, I don't know if like
it sounds more like leader of
the mob or something to me.
- [Girl In Yellow] Baby It's Cold Outside
That's it, end of song
After half a drink?
You been roofied honey.
She just roofied her!
After six drinks I'm still standing so
Don't tell her it's cold outside,
give her a freaking jacket and a scarf
and keep it moving, keep it pushing.
Yeah, drive her home.
There you go, call her a
Uber if it's cold bruh.
If a girl says, I wanna
go home, let her go home.
If a man says, let him go home.
And it's just like you've
been really been grand
and after he's said all
this horrible stuff to her.
It's like women, we just feel like,
you don't want to hurt people's feelings
even when they're horribly creepy.
And that's what's going on with this girl.
It got so dark so quick ahh!
Give me another candy cane.
Damn, man you already
knew it was a bad song,
I didn't even know and I was
like still singing it like
I'm just gonna go back to Spanish songs.
Let's talk about candy and boots.
It's 2017 right now
In 2017 and 2017
needs to make some new
fucking Christmas songs.
Seriously.
I'm still gonna listen to them.
Me too (laugh), not gonna
kill my Christmas spirit.
Hey ho, hey ho
Santa
Baby it's cold outside,
we're out (both laugh)
(upbeat Christmas music)